what's the lay of the land of great
beers
in um in this expansive world of ours I
like pilsners I'm a Pilsner guy I'm an
ice cold beer guy ice cold pilsner I
like an ice cold beer I like an ice
cold one of the best beer buzzes I ever
had
is uh
we had bought a new house but we weren't
building it and over covered I didn't
drink for like three months four months
until we decided to go back out on tour
and we figured that out and I was in the
backyard Leanne came back with like two
tall boy German pilsners and cracked
them she goes let's have a beer and I
was like [__] yeah
and man that second that beer buzz is
different than anything yeah because the
second it it touches you you feel the
Sparkle and you're just like
yeah baby I'm back and then she's like
you want another one I'm like [__] yeah
and then we have another one and then
and that beer buzz is especially
afternoon beer buzz is just so pretty
it's different than a night beer buzz
night beer buzz is like I guess we'll
have a beer and then I'm a couple I
gotta go to work tomorrow all right but
that afternoon irresponsible beer buzz
pilsner pilsner there's I don't mind an
IPA but it's got to be out of It's gotta
I got to be at somewhere I gotta be at
somewhere like they gotta have an IP
like I like a local IPA it's got to be
food involved and then I'm enjoying an
IPA
uh I I threw up an IPA in a bathtub and
uh Salt Lake City one time
it was like what do you mean oh you
throw up in the bathtub okay no no I was
drinking in the bathtub like bathtub
with some water in it or no no no no no
you're sitting in the bathtub no I'm
getting ready to take a shower and I had
a growler of IPA yeah it's about six in
the morning yeah I have to fly that day
to Vegas to jump off the stratosphere
yeah all I need is a little bit of a
buzz to get myself on this [__] plane
I have anxiety going through my [__]
head because I'm jump I'm gonna be the
first person to jump off stratosphere
and so I'm drinking an IPA out of a
Growler and a bathtub at six in the
morning
and it just didn't sit right and I threw
it up and I was off ipas for like 10
[__] years yeah I didn't have another
IPA until I was like 46 because I was
like all I could think about was
throwing up that IPA in a bathtub in a
shower and being like uh I'm gonna throw
up thinking about it but yeah I don't I
didn't [__] with ipas for a while and
then during the pandemic I got it I got
back into ipas I was that way with Jack
and Coke Jack Daniels and Coke really
God's so drunk many many years ago that
just couldn't look at it I can't touch I
can't touch uh uh
what's Janice Joplin's drink Southern
Comfort I can't say Southern Comfort she
just drank it straight uh well it was
Southern Comfort is at 40 that's hard
because it's almost like a liqueur
honestly it's really sweet yeah Jack
Jack double Jack on the Rocks lots of
rocks yeah I mean I had a quote that I
got a video that went viral about I'll
never quit drinking yeah and uh I have
not gotten on a plane since that without
having a flight attendant not even ask
what I want walk up with a double Jack
on the Rocks lots of rocks I mean it
happens so on times I don't want to
drink yeah I flew to Austin the other
day I was like I'm not drinking on the
plane because I felt sick yeah and man
he walked up he goes double jacks off
the Rocks I was like [__] you know it
yeah but yeah that's that's my drink uh
uh wait what's your drink I thought
you'd be a vodka guy
well uh vodka I associate with a lot of
moments in my life of happiness because
vodka is associated with shots and
camaraderie
and there's Eastern Europe in general
a bunch of guys get together
and you celebrate life intensely yeah
people fight people just feel people
experience life in a deep way just get
too drunk for for like for a reason but
I don't see that as like drinking
drinking that's like a a journey towards
a destination it's like uh to me
drinking is like whiskey neat
or beer like you said ice cold beer yeah
there's that afternoon beer like for a
person like me who's extremely
regimented and disciplined sometimes
you'll get the situation I just remember
I mean just I remember uh there's a bar
at MIT where I just remember in the
afternoon it was like a business meeting
I sat down we just started with a beer
and they're like really crisply cold uh
some kind of lager and then just one
beer and two beers and all of a sudden
you say [__] it let's just the rest of
the day this is what this is and you
said uh bright like you just life and
nature is beautiful out there and you
just said [__] it to all the meetings
[__] it to everything else just the
camaraderie the the just talking about
life being silly being you know all of
them see that see you're describing
something I'll never get because I'm not
regimented
I would love I would love
I would love I only for the moment that
you get to have you get the most
precious little Angel's breath that
anyone's gonna get because you live this
life that's dialed in and it's scheduled
and so when you say [__] it it's like
that's like me doing coke like it's like
oh [__] it like and you can just do that
with beer that is [__] amazing I
would love to live a regimented life
just to get the chance to go
hey guys I'm not performing surgery
today [__] it
hey guys yeah this this Bus full of kids
kids gotta It's gotta drive itself home
[__] it